DON DODGE: Hi.
I'm Don Dodge, and this
is Google Root Access.
Today I have a special guest,
my friend and colleague Louis
Gray.
Welcome, Louis.
LOUIS GRAY: Thanks for having
me back on the show, Don.
DON DODGE: Hey, it's
great to have you.
So you wrote a blog post
recently, something about you
don't get a medal
just for showing up.
What did you mean?
LOUIS GRAY: I have
a five-year-old boy
who's in Little League.
And every day he's
constantly telling me
about how he's going
to get a medal.
And he's just going
to get two trophies,
and this'll be his second trophy
because it's his second year.
And when you're
five years old, you
might get a participation
trophy for being in the league.
But when you're an adult and
when you're participating
in the workforce, be it in
Silicon Valley or anywhere
around the world, you don't
get a presentation medal
just for showing up.
So my blog posts
have been something
I've been thinking about, not
just for months but for years,
about people's sense
of entitlement,
people's sense of
risk and working hard,
and how there's really
this calculation of effort,
the amount of work that
you put into something,
the amount of hours that
the amount of thought
and innovation
you put into something
against market opportunity
and against risk.
The people who are
the household names,
be they the Steve Jobs
and the Bill Gates
and the Marissa Mayers and
the Jack Dorseys of the world,
they are all the
products of people
who saw something and
took exceptional effort.
Nobody just shows up to
Silicon Valley and sits back
and waits for the
money to roll in.
It might look easy based on what
you read, but it's not real.
DON DODGE: Right.
So you don't get a medal
for being smart or working
really hard either.
So those aren't necessarily
guarantees to success either.
LOUIS GRAY: No.
There's a lot of smart
people in the world.
And one of the exciting
things about working at Google
is I feel like I've
seen a lot of them.
And I know a lot of
people who work very hard.
But the catch is
that even though you
might be an exceptional
employee and you
might be a very
smart person, you
could end up working at a
company that just doesn't work
out based on timing
or market fit
or issues with the product or
unforeseen market conditions.
And I think that's something
we hear a lot in economics.
And on the flip
side, you have people
who possibly, if
you were to stack
rank them, don't work as hard,
but might actually make money
because they were at the
right place at the right time.
There is no crystal ball that
makes this a perfect scenario.
And you see often this
dichotomy of very good,
strong employees who work hard
at companies that don't work
out relative to people who
might have been more mid-level
or possibly underperforming,
but ended up at the company
at the right time when they got
acquired by a bigger company
and they got to write a paycheck
that someone else didn't.
And you could look back at
that and say, woe is me.
I wasn't on the right
side of the ledger.
But the truth is that
you have to keep going.
Something that I know you
and I talk about a lot
is that the ratio of startups
that fail to those who succeed
is very high.
I was always taught 9
out of 10 startups fail.
And I've seen that
number bandied about.
It could be 80%, 50%, 70%.
But we all know that there's
a very good chance when
you take a risk, it might
not end up with a pot of gold
at the end of the rainbow.
DON DODGE: So you're
a big baseball fan.
And in baseball, if you're a 300
hitter, you're a big success.
And those numbers sort of
translate to startups, too.
LOUIS GRAY: Well, they do.
And one thing about baseball
is it's extremely hard.
You fail 70% of
the time, and you
end up being one of the top
10 or top 20 in your league,
depending on the year and the
distance to the mound and all
that good stuff.
But with a startup,
it's not just 70%.
It might be even
higher than that.
And one thing I remember
reading about a lot,
when I first started working
in the Valley 10, 15 years ago,
is that people would
change jobs frequently.
And they were talking about
people not having careers
where they stayed
10 years, 20 years,
30 years at IBM
like they used to.
But they were changing jobs
every 18 months to 24 months.
It was an interesting scenario,
because not only was there
the availability of jobs and
the ability for job hoppers,
as they were called, to move
from company to company,
but people would keep
trying to make it work.
And they never gave
up based on the fact
that the last place
didn't work out.
They just kept going.
And everyone kind of sees
that there is an opportunity.
And sometimes you get
this feeling of the grass
being greener on the other side.
And you see people do
a lot of that flipping.
And so it's no longer like
a black mark on your resume
to say that you've worked
at six places in nine years.
It's almost expected.
DON DODGE: So you
also said there's
this intersection
of skill and luck
that happens in Silicon Valley.
And to extend the
baseball analogy,
sometimes mediocre
players get lucky to be
on great teams that win.
And the same
happens in startups.
LOUIS GRAY: I think
that's a perfect analogy.
You've seen people who end
up sitting on the bench
or don't even play; they're
on the disabled list.
And yet, the next year they
get a World Series ring.
And you go, well, come on.
Here's a guy who
maybe won 25 games.
That's an incredible
year for a pitcher.
But he played for
the third place team.
Luck didn't work
out in the playoffs,
and they didn't get to go.
The same thing is true
when it comes to business.
Even if you read all the
tomes from Jack Welch
and the other guys who've
been there and done it before,
it doesn't mean that
you're guaranteed
to have a positive outcome.
One thing I remember
specifically,
when I was at Berkeley my senior
year and the year afterward,
I would go to the
city public library,
and I would read all these
stories about Silicon Valley.
I remember specifically reading
one about Larry Ellison,
where it said if you know
the difference between God
and Larry Ellison it's that
God doesn't believe he's
Larry Ellison, one of the
most memorable titles.
And I remember
having a conversation
with a friend of mine.
And she almost
mocked me and said,
why are you reading these books?
It doesn't mean that
by reading these books
you're going to end
up in the Valley.
And I kind of want to
turn around now and go,
well, here we are.
We're actually
working at Google.
It's very cool place
to work, and you
have to impact on these
really innovative things.
But just because you read
about it or you know about it
doesn't mean that you're going
to have that mastery of it.
And it doesn't mean that
even if you do everything
to the best of your
ability that you're
going to be the guy with
the trophy at the end.
And so I wanted to
put this post up.
What I've been
really thinking about
is you see a kind
of an assumption
from the outside world
about what the Valley is
like, that there's a gold rush,
or that you go to Sand Hill
Road and get funded,
not once but thrice,
or that you should be
able to join a company
and 18 months later go IPO.
I think both you and I have
had real business experiences
at companies that--
yourself with Napster
is a fantastic example, at
a company everybody knew,
and everybody knew it
would be the hot thing.
And you didn't get
rich from Napster.
And I was at a company
for 8 and 1/2 years
where we grew from first
customer ship all the way
through filing for IPO,
not once but twice.
And very interesting scenarios
all the way through as you
go through rounds of
layoffs and venture funding.
And the type of things I
think you and I have seen
could fill books.
And that's part of what I
want to get that story out,
for those who haven't
been here yet,
or those who have only seen
the good news, that they should
know that there's a flip
side to the coin, too.
DON DODGE: Well, that's a
good topic for another show.
But that's all we
have time for today.
So thank you for joining us.
I'd like to remind you
if you're a developer
and you're building
applications on the cloud,
you might try the
Google Cloud Platform.
We have a special
$2,000 credit for anyone
who would like to try it.
And the details
are on your screen.
Thank you very much for joining
us and see you next time.